there's a crime detectives follow the
clues they get close but then they reach
the water so they call in the underwater
criminal and investigator that's Mike
Barry hold on this is Mike Barry I dive
in very strange places looking for very
strange things
mike has been an underwater criminal
investigator for 35 years how easy is it
to get rid of a murder weapon all it is
is a flick of the wrist and someone's
mind that murder weapon is forever gone
you have no idea there are people like
me crazy enough to go down here search
law enforcement depends on guys like
Mike to preserve and recover evidence
your three cores in underwater Criminal
Investigation is body recovery vehicle
recovery and evidence recovery I get
called about twice a week sometimes more
sometimes less and when a call comes in
chances are Mike's in for a challenge
some of these locations are absolutely
disgusting our typical dive site is dark
it's deep it's cold it's full of
obstructions it's contaminated the
danger is there when you get in the
water you know I've had murders tell me
you know you'll never find it I said
well we'll see there's nothing like
finding the target when your hand hits
it and you feel it
and you realize you've got it for a
public safety diver there's no greater
thing and when he's out there searching
for a body I look at it as an honor
because you realize the importance of
what you're asked to do there's a family
and there's no closure until you bring
them up you know not every diver can do
this not everybody has it in their DNA
it's what I was meant to do I couldn't
think of anything better to do with my
life truth is I can't wait for the next
to help someone in some way either to
bring closure or to bring a conviction
[Music]
some of the greatest works of art are
just beneath the waves standing in just
25 feet of water off the coast of Cancun
Mexico
the Messiah sub Aquatica at the arte is
both a monument to human creativity and
the natural beauty of the Caribbean reef
ecosystem the museum is a vast
collection of underwater galleries with
over 500 sculptures many focused on
themes of human interaction and impact
on the environment the Marine Park where
the museum is located is one of the most
visited stretches of water in the world
with nearly 800,000 visitors each year
immense pressure is placed on the native
reef ecosystem that's why every
sculpture is made from cement suitable
for the growth of coral seaweed and
algae the many holes in the sculptures
make perfect homes for marine wildlife
to colonize and feed off the coral the
hope is that as nature continues to
colonize these statues they will
transform into massive reefs
unrecognizable for what they once were
and it's also attractive to humans it
has become one of the most popular dive
locations in the area hopefully
signaling a more prosperous relationship
between man and nature
[Music]
when I first started treasure hunting
I'll come down to the river pretty much
every single day and I'll surf and rap
and have a good time at the river for
the first time I went underneath the
water it just opened my eyes to a world
I didn't know existed my name is Jake
Kohler I'm a free diver and treasure
hunter ready still man on diovan a
Chattahoochee River in Columbus Georgia
which is one of the world's largest
urban whitewater courses ever built so
this is actually Georgia and the other
side the river is Alabama thousands of
people go down this river every single
year and they leaves all kinds of
valuables and it's a lot of fun to go
out there and swim and see if I can find
some stuff they've lost some of most
interesting things I found definitely
have to be like iPhones GoPros pistols
[Music]
always pretty interesting to find like a
potential murder weapon out here in a
river but GoPros and phones definitely
my favorite finds when I find these
cameras and phones I try to just figure
out what it belongs to because not only
like finding this stuff is a lot of fun
but giving back the devices that they've
lost is also a blast becoming be careful
out here
oh well not only you find a lot of cool
stuff that people lose after rafting but
thousands upon thousands of fishermen
come up here and
normally no one would go out there and
collect all these fishing lures but I go
out there and I'll free him from the
wall I'm freeing from a stumps and it
just kind of cleans up the area and I
get free fishing lures there's a lot of
animals underneath the water you got a
lot of striped bass shad spotted bass
and catfish you see a lot of turtles
down here too if she's just super
beautiful to see all that stuff first
day back to Jake finds a GoPro he was
diving right next I was really surprised
how many people were interested in
watching treasure hunting videos today
hey we got another fan over there guys I
love coming down here look for treasure
and surfing and having a good time but I
didn't know I can actually do this as
like a full-time job I started my
youtube channel and record myself
swimming and having a good time at the
river and one thing led to another and
now I'm able to do this is I'm a full
time job
[Applause]
[Music]
the more I travel the more I realize
that this spot is actually one-of-a-kind
there's not many places in the world
that you can actually surf at a river
you know you could fish and treasure
hunt I have a love for this River man
and I just can't stay inside I have to
go down and have a good time
[Music]
God wasn't known for being the most
forgiving game but there's nothing quite
like shanking your ball into the drink
or pond that's where this guy comes in
here at TPC Sawgrass hundreds of golfers
lose their balls to the infamous par-3
17th hole but one golfers misery is
another man's gold this is gordon davis
my name is Gordon Davis and I'm a
professional golf ball diver he makes a
living diving for golf balls all over
Florida avid diver for golf balls
approximately 50 years there are a lot
of balls to be found on average I've
when I'm diving I pick up three to four
thousand three or four thousand three or
four thousand whoa so how do you find
these golf balls
it's mostly you know just feel picking
them up out of the mud and some places
much too deep that you can't do nothing
with it you know and it's that mud that
makes it impossible to see well anything
most courses they very few that if it
has clear water most of them poor
visibility because of the algae and all
that so what happens next after I pull
the balls out they go through pick out
some of them and they take them from
there they being someone who wants to
repurpose these balls these balls are
authentic these authentic balls are
diced up placed in all sorts of usable
keepsakes like cufflinks watches and
bottle openers and Gordon he knows what
it takes to be a professional golf ball
diver well I tell people you got to be a
kind of a special cat and be a golf ball
diver somebody was grit and it wants to
be a independent person it's luckily any
other business someone has to do it
everybody has a different job and this
is having to be Ryan
seeing as you're kind of a special cat
any advice for golfers trying to keep
their balls drive yeah take up another
sport
[Music]
hole-in-one commentary's are very large
they're one of the largest animals in
the ocean certainly they're the largest
of any of the raised species they can
get up to about 25 feet across when they
come towards you and they're that size
they look like an alien spacecraft as
they go overhead they actually blight
out the Sun it's just so incredible to
be that close through such a large
animal especially one that you don't
have to fear
[Music]
my name is Andrea Marshall I'm a mentor
a researcher and a marine biologist I've
been in love with the ocean all of my
life
ever since I could remember I wanted to
be a marine biologist when I moved out
to Africa with the intention of studying
things like great white sharks I
actually shifted my focus over to manta
rays when I realized that no one had
ever done a study on that race before
[Music]
one of the things that makes manta ray
so special is that they're large and
sometimes people feel frightened by them
just because of their sheer size but
actually they're one of the most gentle
animals in the entire ocean
[Music]
manta rays are a very intelligent animal
they actually have the largest brain of
any marine fish but one of the things
that surprises me the most is just the
fact that they seek out encounters with
humans so this is an enamel that swims
away from you this is an animal that
swims to you they recognize you almost
as a friend
[Music]
southern Mozambique is just an
incredible location I've lived here for
the last 15 years and even though I
travel all over the world to do my work
I enjoy coming back here because this is
such a wild place it's so exciting one
of the reasons I began work on matches
is because I knew that these animals
were under threat recently you know
within the last 15 to 20 years they have
started to be fished for Asian tonics
and as a result of this we've seen Manta
populations crashing across the globe
even here in Mozambique where we don't
even have a very aggressive fishery
we've seen the population collapse by up
to about 98 percent over the last 15
years we're starting to lose them faster
than we can study them so it's really
important for me to get these messages
across to people who don't have the
opportunity to peek down into the
underwater world
[Music]